what makes you nervous
big monologues
uh shakespeare i've never done
shakespeare i don't know that i could
handle that uh
big monologues how long does it usually
take you to memorize are you a good
memorizer i'm not a great if i'm in
rhythm like if i happen to be inside a
show or a movie and it's like third week
and i got my rhythm and character
then i'll then i'll be fine but if it's
like first week or like first day and i
have the chunky monologue first day
that would terrify me that would be well
you played press secretary right yeah so
didn't you have a lot of monologues a
lot of that you could read you know it's
just like all right i got a bulletin and
then you could just have your bullets in
there right because that's what they do
they kind of like go um well
and you would do that yeah so you
wouldn't memorize them you didn't some
things you didn't have to memorize yeah
but some things you know occasionally
you have big monologues but i feel like
veep
was never really in the big monologue
world very rarely it was always like
repartee and just being bulletproof as
somebody insulted you sometimes how is
it working with julie louise dreyfus
you've you've answered this i know i had
the name dropper just so people think
i'm a big deal but by the way she's just
like i i've always had the biggest crush
on her yeah i think she's phenomenal she
is she's a force she's the best she
really is she's wonderful
kind
hilarious uh tirelessly wants it to be
amazing like she does everything right
generous
uh
a great leader you know
i think that the
thing with a show or a movie if like
number one on the call sheet is a mess
or if they're not great then it just
goes downhill but if she's like atop the
list and she's setting the pace it just
makes everything like
you know flourish i just imagine her
always being pleasant on set hi matt how
are you good morning i don't know that
she's like a chipper like good morning
great day we're gonna kill her today
i don't think she's she's like no no i
think she's real i think she's just real
like she's probably quiet in the morning
and worried about her lines just like we
are you know what i mean like
so
but yeah